[Music] It
's nice when you can move the
emotions of another person with music
by raising your hand inside and
moving them.
[Music]
My name is Dons Algarán, I was born in Buenos
Aires, Argentina, and we are here in Los
Angeles to do a show with my group.
from chips islands tonight
playing the sips and jazz is jazz with
just string instruments with violin
and double bass and guitars
[Music]
today I'm with a quartet they are
some of the best musicians
I've ever worked with what we do
It is taking the traditional sub sillas and
inevitably it was mixed with all the
information from Argentina that I brought to the
group and together we achieved a sound
at the age of 11 they gave me my first
guitar and from that day on I
fell in love with you and with music.
I would get up early to play the
guitar and I would fall asleep with the
guitar.
I think that today's event,
especially for me, is going to be very
fun because I know quite a few months.  s that
we don't do a show the angles
[Applause]
work as a musician is very hard I struggle
to stay afloat I think that every
day
[Music]
the way I manage to overcome
all this is the same fear my own
insecurities I
turn them over  In my music,
when I finish a piece of music,
any emotional catastrophe that I
have had inside disappears and is reborn there
[Applause]